all right y'all we are back and we've
got Maestro Kao and violin hanging out
with my band
y'all yeah Maestro our next guest though
is one of the most prolific children's
writers of this generation so far his
diary of a wimpy kid lean in for this
folks his this Series has sold more than
290 million
books what and has been turned into
seven movies I mean it's it's like I
don't know a family that doesn't have
these books in their house um his latest
book in The Collection no-brainer is out
now everybody say hello to Jeff
Kenny so there's are 18 books are the
original that's the Original Series
right yeah that's the main Series yeah
yeah we have those we were discussing I
have all these in my house that's
awesome yes they're so massively popular
like where did this the origin of all
this start well I wanted to be a
newspaper cartoonist but that didn't
work out for me me um I'm glad it didn't
I appreciate that so I tried for a
number of years to get Syndicate it
didn't work out nobody liked my stuff
and I was keeping a journal at the time
and I thought you know what this format
of text and some pictures is really
appealing nobody's ever really done this
before so that's how I got the idea for
dire of a Wimpy Kid and Greg Heffley it
took me eight years to put it together
and then I found a publisher right here
in New York oh my gosh I mean what the
lucky publisher that said yes to that
idea I'm like good Lord so you're Greg
right is a little bit of Greg yeah
unfortunately not unfortunately so
relatable I've got more hair than him
but he's got a he's got a uh he's a
complicated character he's kind of a a
mass of contradictions and Imperfections
just like I was as a kid and just like I
am now and everything's just EXA
exaggerated for Comic uh reasons yeah I
mean I think a lot of people relate to
that that's why kids like it too like
it's relatable I think so too if you
look at Greg on the cover of the books
he's like he looks like he's having a
hard time of things and I think if I put
a smile on his face and made him look
Brave or strong it wouldn't be the same
book I think you need to know that other
people are having trouble too yeah I
think that that's very comforting so
where do you write where do you go to
because I write songs like anywhere
where do you write well believe it or
not I actually do a lot of my writing in
the
cemetery which seems dark yeah it seems
a little bit dark but I what yeah
there's a picture I think um but uh my
kids were doing you know remote School
during the pandemic and I needed a quiet
place to work so I got a guy in my car
got a blanket and some some Skittles and
some double stuff Oreos oh my God you're
a college kid I love this right now it's
amazing okay so my books are really
fueled on that kind of food It's s oh my
God that's why it's so relatable to kids
that's amazing so this new book is
called no-brainer right yeah so what
what's different about this one this
one's about it's like a satire of the
American education system it's about
Greg's school getting shut down because
they do poorly on their standardized
tests but then the school demands that
if they don't you know raise their
grades with less money then they're
going to be closed for Good so that's
what the book's all about and I also
touched on things like uh you know
School budgets and in school advertising
and book Banning too I I saiz that
because of course it's a Hot Topic yeah
so tell us about it's a no-brainer tour
right and it's helping schools and
libraries that's right we're helping
School schools libraries and well School
libraries and community libraries we're
giving away
$100,000 um we're doing this game show
format which is really cool it's
different than a regular author event
and we're uh rewarding Librarians
spotlighting Librarians because now more
than ever Librarians need to be
cherished and uplifted yeah and my kids
my I love the library at our school
growing up but my kids that's the thing
they talk about the little reading Nooks
that they have at their school they love
it it's like escapism for them it's so
important for kids of all Stripes to be
able to see themselves in the pages of
the book represent in a positive way
absolutely well you're awesome thank you
for being on the show such a fan I'm a
bigger fan now we need a quick break
everybody but we have a nine-year-old
here who says he's Jeff's biggest fan
like biggest he has no idea Jeff's here
so Jeff's gonna go hide and come out for
one giant surprise it's going to be
really great so Jacob thank you for
being here and also are you a fan of
books you like you like reading yep yeah
is Diary a wimp kid one of your
favorites yep
yep so why do you love these books so
much I like them because it's about a
middle school kid who's misunderstood by
his parents also I like that the
character that the main character Greg
relates to me a lot he's not that good
at sports he doesn't like to sweat he's
he like he likes video games he's really
good at video games yeah I love video
games too um so you do you know anything
about U I think Jeff is the writer right
of di wimpy kids so do you know anything
about Jeff Kenny not much about his
personal life but I know but yeah but I
know that he's always thinking up good
ideas and putting them into writing yeah
is that something that you think you'd
be interested in doing when you grow up
yep I've already made some books like
what yeah that's crazy cool what are
they about well one of them is called
John versus the glypro glps yes and the
gpp glps are these aliens who kidnpped
the entire town I love I would
and and and John and his hamster have to
save the entire town also this is a
great
idea that's an awesome idea so you want
to be an author when you grow up yep yep
yep I love it well um I have to let
Jacob in on a little secret because we
invited you here to review no-brainer uh
but that wasn't all we actually I have a
surprise for you do you want a surprise
do you like surprises yes okay okay
that's good cuz because it was happening
regardless Jacob P so the creator of the
Diary of a Wimpy Kid series Jeff Kenny
is here and wants to meet you is that
cool yeah look at you right now come on
out
Jeff come on
[Music]
out how you
do good to see
you Jacob this is awesome I can't
believe I'm getting to meet you you're
like a leg Legend everybody knows about
Jacob I've heard all about your stories
and you're like an expert at the Diary
of wiia kid books aren't you mhm this is
pretty cool this is cool look at this
you completely pivoted his entire
physicality he's like I'm not sure about
this he said and who is she and then I
love it no say that I love it I love it
is that a good surprise yep
yeah J Jeff do you want to say anything
to Jacob yeah first of all thank you for
being a fan but I also wanted to say I
have a studio in planville Massachusetts
in my bookstore on the top floor it's
really cool it's really colorful it's
like the center of the wimpy kid world
and I would like to invite you and your
family up to spend time with me in the
studio draw on my computer and we'll
have some pizza and talk about books and
talk about your books does that sound
like a good idea y all
right GRE all right let's see the deal
oh my God I love you too y'all should do
something together um well we need we
need a break I don't want a break cuz
it's so special but pick up Jeff's
latest book everybody Diary of a Wimpy
Kid no-brainer it's out now and everyone
here is going home with a
[Applause]
[Music]
coffee
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home